[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are currently off the
Record yo let's do
it I like that one that's a new one all
right we got a question from a fellow uh
podcast called why not podcast these
guys are big fans of JK I I posted them
before on the JK Caro and James big
shout out to you James and uh for all of
us and it is what is your most toxic
trait ooh my I'm Petty as Fu trait
that's your most toxic trait yeah I
think so what do you think it is but is
it also like you embrace it you like it
or you know how to channel it in a good
way I like it because I I find it funny
that I'm this way because I can step
outside of myself and see that this way
but I'm also actually this
way that's a really good
way most toxic tra D sometimes question
I think talk something that can be toxic
is also good like for example like the
thing that you love in a person can also
be something that get annoys you the
[__] out of it you right so like let's
say someone's caring as [__] so you're
like oh I love how caring there they're
always thought but then it could also
backfire to where you're like you're so
[__] like annoying overbearing stop
carpet for somebody else yeah or the the
mom that like loves her kids too much
that ends up coddling or enabling them
yeah so I feel like exactly
that for me would be how much I believe
in something and I get tunnel vision
that once I'm on it like I'm obsessive
about it so then I I think if I channel
that well then it's like I can channel
that in a way where it's like we're
going to [__] make our dreams come
true right but if I channel that bad
then it can go like I obsess over um reg
things or something you know hell yeah
yeah I'll get you [__] what's a
tell us a time where it was the Revenge
part it was very toxic so these guys in
high school um one of one of these uh
this guy had an ex-girlfriend right they
just broke up I had no idea and then um
I hooked her up with something in class
and she was thanking me that day with
cookies so she hooked me up with some
cookies I didn't know they were broken
or whatever and he saw her give me
cookies so he got hella jealous he went
on her account and at like 2: in the
morning was like hey I'm at this party
there's all these weird dudes I need
help can you come pick me up so I was
like all right sure so I pull up to the
driveway and when I pull up um bunch of
mask guys come bash my car and then like
I'm inside I couldn't turn on the key
and then they stick stick their hands in
they pepper spray all inside so I'm just
covered in pepper spray they [__] run
I drive back my car is just destroyed
all the glasses broken my mom's like
what the [__] happened to you and then
she took my car to the uh you know to
the auto shop had to pay hundreds of
dollars and I was so [__] mad after
that that um so the main guy he went to
the military so he's gone so I went down
to list and I started looking for every
single one of these guys found out that
um I I I asked her I was like can you
get me the names cuz it's [__] up like
what they did to us and then she was I
had no idea I'm so sorry he had access
to my account so I I decided to figure
out who these guys were or who his
friends were so I went down the list I
got one guy in the middle of the street
me and my buddies took care of him
another guy found out he worked at a
barber shop so I decided to go get
haircuts from him and then every week I
would visit him and have conversations
and and I was just deciding what I might
do while he was cutting my hair and then
one day he said Hey Joe uh I'm sorry
what happened to you but I wasn't there
and then I never confronted him about
what happened but it was kind of a good
feeling to know that I I was [__]
with him and
then while I was getting my haircut I
was just like
stewing I can go and maybe stab him one
day but if he's
apologizing maybe really wasn't there so
I asked him who was there and if you're
willing to tell me then you know we can
be friends like I don't care I I don't
really have any hate toward you I know
you're just backing your friend up and
then he gave me the names and then um I
was been I just been fortunate enough to
be able to get my revenge like on some
of them yeah how were the cookies how
are the cookies the cookies were kind of
salty came in them not worth it
dang but then yeah this is me what 19 20
I don't know I forgot but I I feel like
I don't know if I do those things now
but I spent a lot of time like so angry
and looking at where these guys were
where they live where their families
were at and all this stuff and it's like
after a while it's like why it's a lot
ofal real so sick that you did that it
is that's a cool [__] story it's
[__] sick you're like that Mom that
hunted the cartel down oh yeah that's
tight but I also have empathy where I
know like if if it was on the other side
and if like one of my friends told me
this guy's [__] my [__]
ex-girlfriend and she broke up with me
I'm like what do you want to do and then
it's like well we're going to go bash
his car you know then I would have been
the [__] knucklehead that said
whatever you say we're going to go do it
and then so I got all of the people
around him but the guy cuz he ran away
yeah damn so we still have to finish the
job one more person still got one more
he's still out there well actually B
helped me get a couple of them yeah
wasn't
yeah we were at the a bathroom and and
we uh one of our friends was like some
of those guys are in there Bart came in
see he was one of those guys too it's
like what are we doing all right we're
going to [__] all right let's go who are
you dude and now Bart's on somebody
else's just sitting there now like he's
just built dude he's just like I'm a man
of
peace I would never do anything scariest
[__] me and Joe first became like
friends and we hung so we met at an MMA
gym [__] around and we realize like
we really like to be goofballs and
sometimes you know we're like hanging
out and you have like deep talks when I
heard that story I was like dude that's
[__] up and then I'm and then you know
when you have like that sworn Brothers
Moment Like if we ever catch him they're
[__] dead they're dead that's the
funniest thing is Bart had nothing to do
with it a blood nothing to do it with
when he was [__] up some guys that
had nothing to do with it I'll be petty
over your guys' [__] we still got
against that one guy we are all tatted
you guys we're all [__] and then we
were at and then we're in like Little
Tokyo and then I was like uh we're all
hanging out drinking there and then I
remember like seeing them I'm like oh
[__] those are the fellows that Joe was
talking about hey but if you can call
them fellows did you I don't know why if
they were hell big Simone guys would you
be like I handle a joke no we'll figure
it out we'll figure out a way we're like
I can always go like this and bar can
push him hell yeah that's a technique
dud I was like Joe I think I just saw
him I think they went into the bathroom
and I was like what do you want to do
and he goes let's get him and and so him
me the other guy that has this tattoo oh
yeah and then we found out there's other
surprise attacks in the back like I
guess all the dudes that we thought it
was just him but there's other dudes in
the bathroom that was also peeing that
are also his friends oh so it turned
into like a [__] WrestleMania
supposed to be a one-on-one between me
and the guy while Bart and the other guy
holds the door but then yeah there were
other guys in the bathroom that started
punching me in the back of the head when
we were going at it did you tell them
it's one-onone only yeah one V one no it
was [__] kamakazi attack dude hey gck
rules what the [__] One V one yeah damn
dude yeah I almost forget about stuff
like that but that used to consume so
much of me you know that used to just be
like for the stupidest reasons too and
then there's other things where I'm like
I still kind of get like that but I
still get satisfaction of knowing I know
everything about this person but they
don't know that I know it's such a
that's still like if that happened today
if somebody really wrecked your car like
that that's still a pretty big [__]
thing that's true but I i' be able to
that how do you pepper spray how you get
pepper spray out of your inside of your
car saw those Christmas trees hang them
everywhere everywhere dude I didn't even
know I was pepper sprayed I just felt
like I was crying and I was like driving
and I was like hitting I thought like so
emotional I did just get be [__] jump
and it's so hot in the middle of
winter and then the windshield was the
windshield was all broken in the money I
thought that all the air was making my
eyes irritated I was running red lights
and [__] trying to
F and then I went home and I was like
[__] dude I guess when wind really Gets
In Your Eyes [__] you up and then I
realized they pepper sprayed me yeah and
my mom was like smelling it in the car
and [__] yeah god dude that's a massive
thing to do I your mom starts crying
you're like Mom don't cry it's okay I'm
okay who has pepper spray in high school
like that all because you got cookies
when you weren't supposed to yeah you
did no good deed as they say but what
were you hooking her up with though what
would you get you know I don't know we
always used to like no it was nerd [__]
it was literally like there was no
interest I think it was just like
answers or some cheating thing or
whatever like yeah it was like [__]
yeah damn man but I don't know why it
was if I gave a chick some answers or
some stuff and she got me cookie she
saying today's video is brought to you
by Factor shout outs to factor they sent
us a bunch of goodies the smoothies they
have a mango one it is
spectacular and usually like when
there's prepackaged stuff I you I don't
like it okay it's disgusting but Factor
has done a great job and it's only 2
minutes to warm up you could pop that
thing up you can go and it's so good
especially if you're a guy on the go
like me I'm a big fan of fact cuz they
have a huge selection so you won't get
sick of eating the same thing all the
time and if you got different goals
whether you're trying to do keto you
want to do calorie smart or you're
vegetarian or vegan they got you cover
too and it's less expensive and you
could just get it prepackaged ready to
go and super efficient head to factor
meals.com off the Record 50 and use code
off the Record 50 to get 50% off your
first box and two free wellness shots
per box while your subscription is
active that's code off the Record 50 at
Factor meals.com slash off the Record 50
to get 50% off your first box and two
free wellness shots per box while your
subscription is active it's on and
popping bro she's saying something which
one of your toxic traits you want to F
I'm not going after that this guy's
talking about stabbing people I'm sound
like a [__]
[__] please please save me Steve saying
you're not toxic enough is that what
you're saying to stab some
that's notx you didn't do that I thought
about it to sit there and get a [__]
haircut from the dude you might might
stab dud that's sick to be hold a knife
under the [__] cloak that's so badass
the day or Joe has like a gun underneath
the thing he just
like yeah but it's like his third
haircut he's like building rapport with
the guy he's got that [__] that you
know that that cloth over you and he's
got like piano wire in here wrapping
around the Garrett so sick hey but me
and the guy ended up becoming friends
yeah that's creepy when you smile like
that sure sure you did oh we're friends
we're best friends oh yeah no we ended
up becoming friends and now we know
everybody in his family no exactly go
ahead Anthony start with number one [__]
you
U Anthony will you take the rest of the
video need like we can do a special one
we can do like a 25 minutes gender
between the what's going we could do
like a 25 30 minutes I don't know
there's anything else to be toxic what
you think you're perfect no not even
close but perfect I figured it out I
don't have a badass way to come back
from it is all it's different yeah it's
it's hard when you go after that story
what is the definition of
toxic it is it is pretty I I guess like
the easiest way for me to find that is
to think of times where I've been told I
was being toxic yeah and I think that's
a good way to sort of find it but nobody
said that till like 5 years AG yeah yeah
it's I I think like but then I think
like in retrospect I understand when I
was like kind of like how you think back
to find it I think like when my mind
immediately goes to how I treated past
relationships 100% yeah cuz I was the I
was every type of guy that I tell girls
not to date now because understand it
cuz that's how you know and then like
you know I was the jealous guy I was the
the um controlling guy I was every type
of guy and it's like it's disgusting to
me but it's like but it's relieving that
I recognize it internal that you were
ever that way but that's how you learned
and then now like I try to make you know
like cuz today I'm with smack and I try
to be everything that I wasn't so it's
like oh she benefits from me Having
learned like the 10 times I was the
worst [__] guy in the world you know
yep and like real like [__] like real
jealousy real controlling like I didn't
like when um like my girl went out with
her friends without me and [__] and I
would try to like cause riffs so that
she's not friends with them anymore
because I was like jealous of her time
like [__] I mean this is like when I
was 18 is like um abusive and
destructive yeah I think like I think
but then I played an emotional game
which I think is worse like I wasn't a
physical abuser but I was highly like
covertly emotional where like I wouldn't
even make it very um clear that I was
being toxic I would just there would
just be like punishments that were like
she wouldn't understand why she's going
through these
hardships but I get it cuz I'm like Oh
no you're going to pay for this thing
[__] Asian Dad over here dude weird
but I think like after I'm like do I
have to be this scummy like I was like
can't I but then it's because I also
wasn't happy with myself the P of my
hand yeah I think like in terms of toxic
that's that's where my mind always goes
I think like every Rel almost every
relationship before uh 2015 I was
probably not a good choice is it then
only relationship based or is it with
yourself too um I think it comes out in
relationships obviously like if you're
insecure as a person you're going to to
be a bad partner and I think like it's
weird because when you feel the most
secure I think is when you're kind of
not like I went all those years thinking
like oh I have my [__] down I know my
method I know myself but it's like
that's when you really are missing all
of the the blind spots yeah yeah you
don't it's like and because I'm such a
typical dude in terms of like I don't
learn as much until I've lost something
I needed to lose I need to lose lose L
lose in order to like get the lesson cuz
if I keep [__] winning or you keep
giving me the [__] candy I'm just
like oh did it right yeah so I think
every every guy is different but like I
definitely had to like be toxic and then
like see the wake of my destruction to
be like [__] man like some girls that
that I dated like one of my ex's um from
like
200 uh 2012 like one of my really like
we were a we had a really great
relationship uh in terms of being close
but it was very toxic in terms of like
how much emotional damage we both put on
each other she barely started dating a
new guy this year W cuz she had to
recover from that relationship and
that's and she told me that straight up
she was like yeah it was so taxing on
her that like she couldn't like she
couldn't date you're the reason why
women are out there going men ain't
[__] but at the same time internally
they're like they're everything
yeah yeah yeah it's like not that that's
like I I think I'm cool for that but
like when she reaches out to you she's
just like hey I finally got back on the
bike oh that took a long
time it's such a random yeah it's like
it's one she was one of those people
that like we became friends like a
couple years after and then we kept in
touch and like it's it's like I I kind
of tried to repair it in the friendship
like the damage that I did to her and I
tried to like but then like I knew that
it could never you can honestly you can
never fix it I think she's just a slow
[Laughter]
learner you can never really like fix it
yourself it's like a thing where like
she just has to like go off and and try
again and be like oh this is what it's
was meant to be like you know it's also
not my place it's not my place to be
like I'm sure you helped her with the
closure and the healing that you guys
were friends and then you show that you
grew and you you probably apologize I'm
assuming yeah I all the time we had a
lot of [__] to apologize to each other
about but like I kind of the difference
is I knew what I was doing and she
didn't so that's where it goes into a
different life so you feel like yours
was premeditated murder she was was like
murder of Slaughter vehicular I see yeah
she was in the moment and you were like
planned yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't be on
parole damn well I guess it's Anthony's
term now yeah yeah what is somehow it
always goes back to murder and death
though [__] how do I do this um when
were you abusive and
destructive um is it traits now I think
something yeah see everybody's talking
about past things as if I'm still petty
[__] well I think I think I think these
traits never really go away you just
learn how to [__] like I know that's
a part of me to be like that and I try
to [__] suppress it forever you know
I do think sometimes that I do get in
trouble especially relationship wise too
from Nina and stuff like that because
like I know that I'm like I can be witty
or like quick with my words or or just
know how to like construct my words in a
way that like is I guess just borderline
articulate enough to get myself out of
situations or to explain something so
like the ultimate gas
lighter I get too
dude I just wish you could just give me
space and respect the way you respect
everybody else
okay this is why I'm uncomfortable guys
I don't want to talk anymore no he's
doing it he's doing it he's doing it
he's gas liting
smoth SM that was Fu how could you get
gas L you idiot
he's quick at popcorn Nick oh he's too
good go ahead man go ahead finish your
example of when you did that and you
caught it no I think like for example um
I'll even be able to like I can know
when I'll do something wrong and I'll
know how to apologize for it and I like
I honestly give myself enough like
respect because I couldn't do that when
I was younger so I've grown from that
and I know how to apologize but I still
find myself using my words and
apologizing in a way that still might
like I don't know self- preses my the
nature of why I did something okay you
know what I'm saying it's never like
it's like gray to you now even yeah it's
it's never fully like damn I was just
wrong it'll be like man I was really
wrong really sorry like let me make it
up by blah blah blah blah and like put
myself in a space that just like allows
me to I don't know walk through that
moment without as much guilt as maybe I
should hold on to you're trying to get a
w you still maybe yeah yeah maybe you
know what I'm saying hand because bend
the L into a freaking DB that's it for
[__] in there yeah that looks
right yeah yeah ex you um but creases in
that W though it used to be L here it's
a Walmart yeah you see the creases in
the metal but like I I I'll have to like
tell myself like literally have to have
a conversation with my brain and be like
no dude like this is where you Mees
messed up understand where like she or
they are coming from whether it's
somebody I work with or whatever you
know what I mean and and do what you got
to do to like put yourself in that their
position but then there's still somehow
this like underlying okay this is why I
did it BL like as if I I can't just be
sorry for it I have to have like
reasoning that like allows my apology to
like make more sense to me you know what
I'm saying I see something about that in
myself where I was like I can work on
that I can work on just being uh or just
maybe understanding them more versus
needing to understand me in that moment
yeah you know what I'm saying sure right
cuz when if like if you made a mistake
then the other person deserves to be put
first in every way exactly but you know
that's the thing like uh conversely if
it's like not an issue or if it's not a
problem I did do something wrong that
same you know wit if you will is useful
or is like fun to be around or like
inspiring and stuff like that like in
terms of like like using your pow for
good yeah but then when it's like using
it for yourself then it could also be
toxic just like Joe was saying sometimes
your best traes are often times your
worst you turn that into a W2 yeah that
was sick so good he's good I like being
G by
him